[Music]
neil's journey at the end of tenet is
arguably
one of the most confusing plot points in
the entire film and seeing things from
the character's point of view
is the only way to really understand
what happened and why
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the journey that he ended
up going on
through the use of reversed footage and
a 3d animation
that really details what happened we'll
also be going over the theory of quantum
immortality
and how the characters in some way live
forever due to theoretical physics
now if this is your first time here
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul now let's go back to
the future as we break down neil's
journey
okay so neil joins the protagonist in
india and follows him on the path to
both the future and past
as he tries to stop sator for the final
mission at stalsk 12
he's separated into the blue team but
after noticing that the entrance to the
hippo's center is booby-trapped he
reverts himself and ends up rescuing
both ives and the protagonist
from an explosion that happens in the
base's core now
during the mission to the hippo center
the protagonist and ives encounter a
locked door
but this is opened by an unknown soldier
seconds before he's shot in the head
after the mission is completed it's
revealed that this is actually neil
and after that he says he will be the
one to go back and unlock the door
meaning that his fate is sealed and we
know that the character died
now ever since doing my neil timeline
video i've had numerous people question
me about the events of what neil did
and whether the way we watched the film
is the way that things happen
now personally i believe that neil saved
the protagonist and then went off into
the helicopter with ives which took him
back to the base and he then
inverted once more went back out with
the blue team and then unlocked the door
however twitter user anecdotes sent me
an edited version of my timeline
in which they said that neil went on the
helicopter and actually ended up going
through the entirety of the movie
in order to unlock the door i think this
theory kind of falls apart because neil
in the end asks if the protagonist is
going to see cat in london
which you wouldn't know about had he not
experienced the events of the film
however if that's the way you want to
view the film then that's absolutely
fine
either way though after rescuing the
pair and being told that the door was
unlocked
neil boarded the helicopter and at some
point he inverted and returned with the
original blue team
during the briefing we can see before
the majority of the team masked
up that there are several people already
wearing them and it would be easy for
this version of neil to sneak in
and join the team without alerting his
past self for those around him
we also see throughout the final battle
that he slips off a notice very easily
and it could even be possible that the
cuts we see of neil interspersed
throughout the climax
are in fact the future version of the
character making his final mission
now as for the final act from his point
of view
neil knows that he's going to be shot
before any of the events take place
and this explains some of his actions in
the finale
after returning to the field neil
obviously either starts off as part of
the blue team
or goes out with the red team and
inverts himself by the turnstile
with the blue team he clears the rocks
that block the passage
and heads in after the explosion has
been set off
whilst his past self on the surface is
with the protagonist and ives
as the decels he races towards the door
and as it's already open from his point
of view
he simply has to go to the other side
and hold it now the reason that he
stands there is because he knows that
his timing has to be perfect
and that he has to take a bullet for the
protagonist in order to not only save
his life
but shock sator's man he waits until the
events plain reverse from his
perspective
and upon seeing the protagonist go
backwards through the door
he then closes it and he is the one who
locks it
now this is very confusing but in order
for it to be unlocked from the point of
view of the protagonist
neil must actually lock it tennis is
very much reversing the idea of cause
and effect
and making it affecting cause and thus
the only way to have the door closed for
the events to play out the same way
is by this happening just after locking
it he's then
shot by saito's man who from neil's
point of view would reverse and then be
told by
sator to shoot him in the head neil dies
at this point
which is when the protagonist notices
the tag on his back
and everyone starts crying on the second
watch anyway
now in many ways the future version of
the protagonist knew that he was sending
neil to his death
and he allowed it to happen because it
was imperative that he saved him in the
past
neil likely knew the mission as well and
was willing to perhaps return the favor
for him saving his life at some point
and his mother which i i don't wanna i
don't wanna go into the kneeler's max
theory
more times than i already have now as
demonstrated in our timeline there are
multiple versions of neil existing
across this action scene
as not only are there two reversed
versions of the character
there is also the one moving forward as
well as the one at the opera
thus neil is technically living forever
in this constant loop
and which is life and death are both
happening at the same time
now this ties into the idea of quantum
immortality and if you know of the
shrouding is cat thought experiment
and it's sort of along the same lines as
that the theory thought up by max
tegmark discusses subatomic particles
that have an upward spin that either
fires or does not fire a gun
but but basically yeah but basically
what it is is if there was
say a revolver with one bullet and you
spun it and then fired the gun
there would be six versions of you
created in which five survived and one
died
because consciousness does not exist at
the point of death your consciousness
would automatically travel into one of
these five alternate realities
and thus you would find a form of
immortality in which you would exist in
the multiverse
neil at one point in the film even says
the line in a parallel universe
you can't know the difference between
consciousness and multiple realities
and this sort of plays into the previous
statement about death
now though teneck kind of brushes to the
side the idea of the multiverse
and it exists in one strict timeline the
fact that neil's consciousness would be
snuffed out and yet still exist
in another body would mean that he would
automatically become
part of this the other character would
be unaware of exactly what's going on
he would in many respects live for
eternity
it is thought that time only exists
because we observe it
and that the universe around us can only
be there because it is what we perceive
just in the same way that it's
impossible to know whether a falling
tree in an abandoned wood makes any
noise
it's impossible to know what truly
happens to consciousness upon death
and some even think that it breaks free
of time and travels back to certain
moments in life in which thoughts have
occurred
if consciousness is not truly bound by
time then that would mean that neil
would upon death travel back to one of
his many bodies in this moment
and that he would simply go through the
motions once more
now that's some high level thinking but
hopefully this video has helped to
simplify the journey that neil ended up
going on throughout the film
i'd of course love to hear your thoughts
and theories on it and as a thank you
for interacting with the video
you'll be entered into a prize straw for
a copy of the hobbit and lord of the
rings 4k
box set we're giving away three and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
getting it is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
i also just want to give a massive shout
out to both webley coffee spill and
mukul say for putting together some of
the footage i used
and i'll link their channels in the
description if you want to check them
out
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the fan theory that sator is actually
working for the future version of the
protagonist
throughout the entire film i definitely
think it'll change the way you watch the
movie
so make sure you click it right now if
not then thanks for sitting through the
video
i've been paul i see you next time take
care peace
just